whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
I've never noticed how black your eyes
were hello my friends now it's Perez
here and I am sitting here with the
stars of Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
Chris Pratt and Karen Gillen it is so
nice to see you guys lovely to see you I
am so excited to talk to you guys about
this movie because Chris decades ago yes
when you were little he would go to your
backyard and you would pretend to be Han
Solo and Luke Skywalker after watching
Star Wars that's right and now here you
sit as the hero of an epic space
adventure Trilogy wow and Karen you
would audition for school plays yes you
wouldn't get cast Never and your first
Guardians was the first movie you were
on on a scale like of this size yeah and
I just feel like the both of you have
grown so much to this franchise and
since this is a culmination of a Trilogy
I first wanted to know what was the last
day on set like and Chris I heard you
gave a speech and I was hoping that you
could maybe share a little bit oh it
does oh gosh I do you know thank you for
all of that and you're right it's been
an amazing ride and the last day of last
day on set of volume three I did did
give a speech I was I'm not like a
vindictive person but
anytime you start that
kind of going somewhere yeah
we're just leaning in now
I happen to have in my notes file
several press clippings saved from the
first movie when everyone predicted you
you remember this yeah that the
Guardians of the Galaxy was going to be
Marvel's first flop that was that that
was like the consensus critically it
felt like everyone was saying all of
these negative things and at the time we
were all pretty insecure and nervous
about the prospects and this and it
stood the reason I suppose objectively
you're saying this is like a title that
no one's ever heard of we don't have any
uh A-list Stars the Guardians of the
Galaxy wow are you ready to be part of
Marvel's first big failure why is anyone
going to watch this movie they don't
know these characters Etc and I remember
all of that and so of course none of
that came true thank God we had this
great run and so at the end I wanted to
read some of those uh clippings uh to
the cast The Crew and specifically to
James and just let it just to I guess
kind of rub it in a little bit but also
just to you know say hey we overcame a
lot to get where we are and and boy we
weren't supposed to be what we are but
we but we we did something special and
just to kind of bask in the in the
moment of that
what this 10 years has been so that was
kind of the last day it was emotional
there's a lot of Tears felt like the
last day of school you know summer
vacation's about to start but it's like
usually that is something really nice
but on your senior year it's a little
different you know when you're like
Summer's starting but also it's not it's
like the summer of our life is starting
we're we're never going to be back
together in school it's a little
Melancholy I also love that so much so
much that there was just so many people
that were like this movie isn't going to
work and it like completely did and it's
like there's such a good message in
there of like do not be disheartened by
people's you know comments or opinions
or beliefs about something because
that's not what's going to dictate it
right yeah and you both have truly just
come so far I love that you brought that
up because James Gunn went through a lot
of different people trying to find
Star-Lord yeah and he said that when you
walked in he knew it was you right away
oh wow back then Chris did you think it
was risky were you like I'm Gonna Be
Acting with a raccoon in a tree like
what were you thinking then what are you
thinking now and what's your overall
reflection on how Star-Lord has changed
to you oh well listen um first and
foremost incredibly grateful
so grateful really it has changed my
entire life the trajectory of my career
the trajectory of my my life in all
aspects personal professional everything
in between
um it changed the way I approached my my
business as an actor and um yeah it's
just it's meant so much it was like
being drafted onto a winning NFL team or
something you know like if you've
dreamed your whole life of growing up to
be a football player and then on draft
day they pick you it's like it felt like
that and I remember I remember reading
listening I don't want to make this
whole interview about how what people
didn't ex what people expected of us and
defining expectations but I remember
there was one article in particular that
when I was circling the idea of uh
auditioning for the role yeah it was
like all the 25 actors we could see
playing Star-Lord and I wasn't on it I
was none of them were me and I was like
oh man maybe it's the 26th guy maybe
it's the 26 guy that's gonna get it you
know maybe it's me and so you just go in
and you do your best and and I did and
thank thank God that James saw something
to me and and wanted to make me the
character and pretty cool it's a high
five yeah I wanted to ask you the same
about nebula because when we met nebula
it was she was such a smaller role and
she's emerged to this like prominent
position in the MCU what's your overall
reflection of her trajectory and how
she's changed you I signed up to this
rule thinking it was eight days of
filming and then I thought that the
character died and now here I am nine
years ten years later and I'm an
official Guardian
the team
it's so excited about that it's so
inspiring to hear you guys talk about it
because I feel like you've had an
emotional Journey getting here but this
movie also feels like it's going to be
really emotional based off your
reactions of the script Chris you read
the script you called it a masterpiece
Karen you read it with palm you started
crying we see Star-Lord crying in the
trailer how much our audience is going
to be crying when they see this movie
what you know of the Guardians of the
Galaxy films the tone of it it's still
it's a similar tone it's fun it's
irreverent it's funny there's great
music it's visually stunning the story
is really great and it's emotional and
that's been really uh constant through
the trilogy I think this film has really
emerged as perhaps the most emotional of
the three just because of the context
this is that we're wrapping up the story
and naturally there's going to be
emotion with that
um so I'm excited about that and I'm
really excited that over the course of
the maybe nine ten years that it's taken
to tell these three stories to audiences
fans have grown up by nine years and for
many of us that doesn't mean much but to
a kid who was 12 or 13 when Guardians of
the Galaxy he came out they're now in
their 20s yeah and they'll be watching
this and they will have matured
emotionally along with these films so
that gets me the most excited thinking
about a 13 to 15 year old kid from when
this movie came out watching it now and
they're out of high school maybe they're
out of college they're you know adults
now and and you know we made it for them
we made it for the kid and all of us but
uh that that particular audience I'm
very excited for them to to to see this
to get emotional about it Karen what do
you think yeah it's definitely emotional
so me and Paul who plays mantis read it
together in a room we were like we
cannot do this alone I think I'm not
sure where in the process it was then we
actually read the script but there was
like yeah a lot of emotions surrounding
the making of the film and our director
and everything but we read it and just
like both were crying together
um but there was also tears of laughter
too oh yeah these movies are so funny
and but you're right they are so
emotional like even hearing Since You've
Been Gone by Rainbow in the trailer like
got me going we all know music is like
such a big part of these movies yes now
that Peter has an iPod like what songs
did you lean on yeah well the Zune he's
got the zoom the zoom that's right it's
one step above iPod technology yes yes
yes oh I mean what's beautiful about
that Zune is it opens us up to an Era of
music that is beyond just the 70s and
what would have been hit music for
Peter's mother I mean Peter Quill's mom
gave him volume one and volume two and
those are songs that she really loved
well this is a woman who would have died
in 1989 so up until 1989
um that's where her musical taste lied
and so there's a lot of great stuff that
came out after that yeah and because uh
of the story with yondu finding the Zune
in this junker shop there's really great
and I we've opened it up and allowed for
some iconic songs to come in I don't
think I want to give any spoilers but
I'll tell you this okay I think it's the
best soundtrack that we've had on all of
the movies it's really definitely it's
moving and he's done it James has done a
great job because you know he of course
curates these playlists of finding those
sleeper hits not like the the the song
that you're like well of course that's a
great hit song and but like you know
kind of bringing something up kind of
like he did with each of us finding
stuff finding this little diamond in the
rough and bringing it up and polishing
it and letting it be on display he does
a great job with that and all of the
songs in this uh in this particular
volume three have that same feeling oh
there's one song that's the opening of
the movie I'm not gonna say what it is
but it is epic that's what that's when I
talked to James he said the same thing
he said we're gonna hear some 90s and I
personally was like I hope torn by
Natalie Imbruglia is in it but after
what you just said it's probably not
[Music]
all right we can't afford to use that
unfortunately but um going back to the
trailer one of my favorite scenes in the
trailer is when nebula is carrying Peter
yeah tell me about filming that scene
and who is she to Peter now because they
seem poor look at these guns wow did you
get arrested for coming in with that
yeah welcome to the gun show I that was
not actually Chris that I was carrying
that was a doll of course yeah they made
it I don't want to know where the most
incredibly yeah
their office I know they made an
incredibly lifelike
full-scale doll that she could carry
specifically for that scene and in the
scene
well can we say what it is let's just
say it doesn't look like I'm
awake okay okay okay am I dead am I
asleep who knows who knows but she's
carrying this essentially lifeless body
yeah and carrying dead weight is a lot
especially with dead weight is like 235
pounds so she's not gonna be carrying me
for this long slow walk and talk so they
made this foam version of me that was
probably still pretty heavy it was
fairly high 30 pounds yeah I had to put
it down in between takes it was down to
literally the moles the hair the pores
so lifelike that literally like the
first time I walked in and saw it lying
there because it has this dead kind of
vibe yeah nice open dead I had a bit of
a um visceral reaction as if I was
standing over myself it was the
strangest thing to see an incredibly
lifelike but Dead version of yourself is
something that I hope no one here ever
sees because I don't think it would mean
that you're dead and you're floating
over your body and you're now in limbo
have you ever seen ghost that's based on
a true story
it's a strange thing to be like whoa
dude I kind of had this I didn't see
this vertigo moment where I'm like this
is what I'm yeah like will I one day be
looking down at my own
language that's gnarly I can't wait to
see nebula and Peter's dynamic because
it does feel like they have just sort of
like a closer relationship this go
around but I wanted to ask you about the
woman in the middle of this Dynamic and
that is Gamora yes Gamora and Peter's
relationship to me has always been my
favorite in the MCU that will they or
won't they energies yes it's so chef's
kiss but the Gamora that Peter knew died
in Infinity War and the one that he's
interacting with now is a past version
of her that we met in endgame so how
does Peter go about wooing the love of
his life when she doesn't know who he is
well listen you're just right in that uh
there is that Dynamic it's even it's
it's a it's a bit of a Trope of the will
they won't they Sam and Diane so much so
that uh Peter Quill remarks about it in
volume two when is this going to be this
thing this will they won't they she
doesn't know what he's talking about and
so yes now she's no longer there and the
way that James addressed this in in
writing the story and directing the film
is so elegant it's so beautiful it's so
forward thinking it's really unlike
anything I've ever seen wow in that type
of dynamic to find new territory to
discover in what is a pretty
prototypical romantic archetype is
really hard to do but because of the
events of infinity war with this blip
and now a person not knowing who a
person is that's a whole new in to this
type of uh uh relationship you may have
seen things like that in like a 50 First
Dates or something like I don't know who
you are but we fall in love this is this
is played very real and it's emotional
and it's really powerful and it's really
beautiful and it's empowering and it's
loving and oh I can't wait for people to
see it and they need to start selling
tissues at concession man someone's got
to get on that um Karen I love nebula's
relationship with Gamora as well thank
you for sharing all that um there was a
line that you said that I think is so
good you said playing nebula is like
playing the scapegoated sibling in a
toxic family Dynamic what a line
it's so good
hear it back to yourself
I think it's very eloquent I feel like
things have changed now though like it
kind of feels like before it was Gamora
trying to get through to nebula now it
kind of feels like nebula is trying to
get through to Gamora how fun was that
role reversal for you with Zoe this time
around I mean it's really fun because
you know nebula started off as this very
like sadistic tortured angry person and
gradually she's just become this
completely new being that can like let
in love and accept love and start to
give love to and I think Gamora has
definitely been set back a bit and
nebula can definitely recognize that in
her because she's seen it in herself and
so I think it's about trying to almost
nurture Gamora maybe back to where you
know she she knows that she this is so
confusing with time travel yeah but yeah
where she would be in the future version
right because so many of the
relationships that Gamora experienced
and the growth that she had in her life
came from the events of Guardians of the
Galaxy one and Guardians of the Galaxy 2
and this is all stuff that happens after
this Gamora that we meet so the
Diabolical kind of insane psychopath
Gamora is a Gamora we're not used to
seeing because she kind of she quickly
sheds all of that for the first two
volumes but for example your your
wonderful fight sequence and sister
dynamic in volume two beautiful we love
it these two tortured siblings who are
given an opportunity to literally
process all of this damage and come out
the other side of it healed and and
better for it well that's out the window
now and so here you are you've healed
but she hasn't and same with Peter Quill
and her we have all these memories these
wonderful things we've both grown so
much well I have but she hasn't so how
do how do you how do you bring someone
back from that and can you yeah I love
that you mentioned the sparring in
volume two because I love seeing you
both go at it and we actually get to see
nebula go at it with Adam Warlock in the
trailer what was it like sparring with
Will Poulter for this movie he is a big
presence you know so it was kind of fun
to fight someone like that
um it was also kind of fun that he just
didn't even eat it he didn't go easy on
her because she's a girl or anything he
just goes at it and nebula is like
definitely like having to deal with a
lot in that situation but I think she
fights back you'll have to see it's a
really interesting fight sequence I'm
excited to see it I I feel like the
action and Guardians to me is just the
most fun I especially love seeing Dave
Bautista fight because he was a former
wrestler and I love Drax and he's kind
of been you know outspoken about how
this is a Bittersweet and for him and
how he's ready to move on to other
projects how much has he meant to the
both of you and how special is Drax too
oh man I mean this has truly been an
extraordinary
God it's tried to say because you hear
it like oh what a journey it's been you
know all these films but it's true it's
the destination is what you see in the
cinema what you're going to see when you
buy tickets now and when you go see it
in the cinema May 5th that's the
destination that's where we were all
headed
it's parking here in a theater and being
swept away for an hour and a half or two
hours on on an extraordinary Journey but
getting to that destination
that's where all of the nuanced kind of
private emotional and wonderful personal
human growth happens in our business
yeah and so getting to know Dave getting
to know Karen and palm and Zoe and all
of our family members and our our kids
and our wives like that whole vibe is
not something that you go see when
you're sitting down watching the
watching the theater so it's sad that
you won't see more this is the last time
you have an opportunity to see us in the
theaters and
we're a bit like circus performers you
know it's like we gotta we gotta pack up
the circus and go and at the end of that
it's it's really hard because you sit
down for several hours every day over
the course of many years getting to know
people because of the circumstance of
filmmaking puts you all together but
then that circumstance dissolves and
you're left to like
am I not going to see this person for
six months am I not going to see Karen
until we're off promoting a movie and
then when when we're done with that then
what it's like we you have to try to
stay in touch but it is what it is
that's kind of the the vibe so what does
Dave mean to me man I mean he's
fantastic I just got him a dog you just
got him a dog yeah I helped him I helped
him adopt a dog I have a friend or
Millie who was Millie Bobby Brown was we
did this film The Electric State and
she's big into finding uh dogs to for
she Fosters them and finds people to be
their permanent homes and I was like
Dave this dog looks like uh you should
get this dog and now it's uh Tallulah
his new dog he has so many dogs I feel
like he just adopted a dog when we were
doing volume three yeah he found this um
little puppy and took the puppy he must
have like a house full of dogs not all
heroes wear capes we love Dave I mean
truly he like that's that shows like who
he is he just takes in dogs he loves
them so intensely like they're his
children it's very sweet wait just
hearing you say everything that the both
of you just said it's like you can tell
that all of you are just such a family
and what's so special about the
Guardians is that the same people have
been working on these movies not just in
front of the camera but behind the
camera too and I feel like at the core
of that is director James Gunn oh yeah
what is James meant to you oh Karen will
start oh God right this is right don't
cry
um
I mean I'm so grateful to him he gave me
a career in films in America he is the
most wonderful director the most caring
person he also is another one that like
takes in a lot of people into his life I
feel like everyone is kind of like got
some interesting story or maybe you're a
little bit lost in some way and he kind
of has formed this whole family around
him and he's truly just one of the most
caring people I've ever come across in
my life and so
that's lovely to be around as a human
but then on set you just feel incredibly
taken care of as an actor and you feel
like he creates this comfortable safe
space where you can make an idiot of
yourself and try stuff and he's gonna
probably laugh at you and make fun of
you but that's okay yeah oh that's true
it's the best he's one of my dearest
friends I talk to him all the time
um
I owe my career to him and uh
being Peter Quill on the Guardians of
the Galaxy changed a big changed
everything and like I said there was a
list of 25 guys that Hollywood wanted to
be Peter Quillen I wasn't one of them
and so he found me and took a chance on
me and you know I trusted him and I I
learned a lot through the process I I
didn't know how to play this character
and he taught me how to do it and uh he
he did a great job he knows how to work
with actors and and knew how to work
with me and um works with everyone
differently he's so prepared he knows
exactly what he wants he's not afraid to
tell me no which is a big uh a big deal
like sometimes I get a little
overpowering with my ideas and my
thoughts and I'm like it should be this
way that's the way I see it in my brain
and I think that should be that way and
it's but it's not my show it's his show
and then in the end I go wow he was
right it should be that way you know so
it's nice to and periodically also he's
not so proud that if an idea comes up
that is good that he'll he'll say no not
that idea because it's not mine you know
he's a real collaborator and whatever's
the best thing that goes on screen and
and for the most part he knows exactly
what that is going to be wow do you
think this is the last time you'll be
playing a superhero for James Gunn
oh I don't know it's
um certainly the last time I'll be
playing uh Peter Quill for James Gunn
um he's not going to do any more
Guardians the Galaxy films and it's a
trilogy but listen I love him and I
loved working with him so I'm open to
anything about that if Peter were to
retired from the Guardians do you think
nebula would take over as leader in what
type of leader would she be a leader of
the Guardian yes I could actually see
her weirdly being being a leader I think
that she would be a little bit more
stern than you I think she would you
know
um
just like the authority that I naturally
have no it's um no I think that that
would be really interesting actually
she may or may not take up some sort of
leadership position not necessarily of
the Guardians but of something in the
movie you have to wait and see cannot
wait while my friends with the teas like
that we gotta end there thank you guys
so much for your time for your art for
your intentionality just for everything
you put into all three of these movies
and for entertaining us you're welcome